[Music]
you beat it
okay
no no no all right so I've got a for I
don't know two weeks ago now do you guys
finally understand why I was killing me
to not be able to talk about it with the
second half of that game yeah there's a
lot about this game whether you play the
original eight or seven or not like the
fact obviously when you get the blades
of chaos that's pretty huge and then you
start to find out who everybody is even
like finding out that the Witch of the
woods is Freya Freya is Boulder's mom
she took those green arrows away from a
trace presumably because she knows they
could kill her son is that why I guess I
think so how did it out
but a lot happens like first off the
blade to Kaos like you just played
through all the games for your video
that he did a recent yeah that part was
pretty awesome that was like that's the
big moment that's like so rewarding if
you play all the previous games because
you know like they build it up so well
he's like I gotta go home yeah yes so
comfortable with the axe the other ice
is criticized understand that he's doing
receptive and and the game takes you
through so many lengths to like proving
it go with it
[Music]
yes and then it's just like oh my god
[Music]
all right Baha let's see what
your your range is extended so much it's
almost it was hard for me to go back to
the axe after getting Lizzie pants I
mean those blades are super awesome just
from a fan perspective to you because
even like even throughout some of the
comments can do they're all like kind of
like really based off of some puzzle you
know yeah like games when you whip them
together and like slaps them in the end
that's square square square square from
the old man really yeah although all the
runic attacks are like based on like
attacks from those old games right right
like it feels really good but it feels
kind of better in this game yeah that
still retains that like I I still need
to like think about what I'm doing and
like think about like enemy management
well those are you acts and they have a
lot of weight to them too they're not
like these things that are you just sort
of swinging like that way nothing but
you can you can sense Kratos is like
hefting his weight entities like heavy
metal chains
I think that's really the best part of
this iteration of the blades because I
mean I was actually talking to you and
former Australian office and you know he
didn't really like the older got bored
yeah because of like just the way that
those blades felt but like we were
talking about how much but just how this
game really like gets across that since
wait like you're actually hitting dudes
these weapons I don't walk away from
video games ever like mimicking what
I've been doing like back in the real
world but like I get through like 20
minutes of playing got war Mike comes up
to talk to me I find myself well I'm
listening to him like we're like good as
ever sighs still got that like energy
built up in me because it's so
convincing you just comes across it
really well so that's what's cool about
this game like it accomplished so much
it's like I almost a soft reboot for the
series itself but they still acknowledge
Kratos has passed as this huge dick who
killed a bunch of people who didn't
deserve it kill the entire pantheon of
Greek gods essentially he killed his dad
Athena comes back right right when you
get the blades right and then she's yeah
she's in the boat on the way back to get
the blades and then on the way out of
the house when you're about to fight all
this dude she's there and he's like he
just walks through it right but there is
one unavoidable truth you will never
escape you cannot change you will always
be
monster
I know
but I am your monster no longer but also
this sets up a new you know saga really
well you know like so whoever it happens
like to be a trilogy or whatever it's a
really great first entry he sets up the
conflict with Freya down the road she
killed her son right and it sets up if
you go back to your house you see Thor
that also raises the question though
because we also find out that Petraeus's
other name is Loki yeah who is son of
Odin right in Norse mythology as we know
it so in in the in the Marvel movies he
is Thor's brother and son of Odin
but in traditional mythology he's not
he's not daunted or something he's like
this like offshoot rogue God who helps
them when he agrees with them but when
he disagrees with him he helps the
Giants so Ragnarok starts when Loki
kills Balder which kind of happens here
and then all that [ __ ] goes down the
Giants go to war with the humans so what
at Reyes or Loki is giant human and God
so he's got like he's pretty much the
centerpiece of this whole Ragnarok thing
presumably Ragnarok has started now
before we've attempted to meet god I
should warn you more time has passed the
new one
all of the gun when you swing balled up
it's becoming something else stuff
not just anyway
spam V summers and when it's done back
Public Enemies there is another thing
where that is definitely twisting the
like the mythology as it's known Mamere
in the game right he's on craters his
belt whole times it's disembodied head
yeah but Norse mythology he's on Odin's
no you're so legit I looked him up
because I was wondering about like well
how much kind of spoil in the review
what is actually known about this
character and like the image that they
show him Wikipedia is like a distant is
just a beheaded body and then I start
reading it's like oh [ __ ] yeah he was
giving Odin advice or inside or whatever
in mythology so that that's kind of
interesting they did that but then
obviously the huge reveal in the second
ending with Thor yeah friend or foe
right
you killed two of sons ya know maybe
he's pissed off at or something I'm like
yeah you see or lunders enemy this world
serpent and him always hated each other
that's why each bit the sat you and
subsequently why totally they talk about
how he's just like filled with bloodlust
and murder all of the Giants I think
yeah it was him who kill it and we meet
with Neil near you killed all the Giants
and Hammer whoever I I feel like that'd
be such an obvious yeah II can your
enemy and put him right there cuz I feel
like Freya might isn't beyond coming
back to help you even though you killed
or [ __ ] up her son but like I like how
her like that final battle with Balder
is Kratos trying to protect his kid even
though it's Reyes is a badass during
that fight he's like diving off the edge
while Kratos do grabs Balder
but then it's also her trying to protect
her son it's that really cool dynamic
between two parents who really have no
other choice I mean I I would have
rather Freya helped us out instead of
screwing us over but I get right I'm not
a parent but I assume it would be tough
to see your kid get the [ __ ] kicked out
of him he kills me I will protect him I
will not let him die I was really hoping
there was gonna be a fight with her in
the game as it is right now
but I've gone back to her place like
through her cave and can't really do
anything they talk about her my mirror
says I go she's probably plotting your
demise right now what are you doing go
in here I can't seem to figure out if
she's gonna be in here or not and that
final fight that's such a great job
gentlemen you mentioned this earlier how
like I see the older games right away a
beginning of two you fight the Colossus
of Rhodes at the beginning the beginning
of three you fight Poseidon you're
climbing all over him and then obviously
likelike Kronos the Titans are enemies
but I love how she starts controlling
the the Mason giant with the chisel
through his head and then a trey is
trying to free you and then all of a
sudden he's like I [ __ ] it and he calls
the world served and the world service
comes out of nowhere a scale of that
battle is just such a good like callback
there were scale when you're talking to
the world servant when you're you know
just like the actual scale of the world
but that would reminded me of like old
school totally yeah I think anyone who's
like concerned about like God does it
feel like our Lord doesn't like that
HEPA components like they really bring
that out at the end there anything it's
just enhanced by the fact that like the
camera just stays so low to you you know
like everything that I just feel like a
tiny dude and all this stuff is
happening hackable because they saved it
to the end yes I don't feel like God or
three which is like it starts off with
like this giant light head thing and
then it kind of scales down and then it
kind of grabs it back yeah and so if
we're gonna have it happen just at the
end it like gave it more weight but
spectacle aside that fight was very easy
are you some of the things that yeah or
that it felt like a really lackluster
sort of challenge at the is long haul so
now it's about what the Valkyries it's
about master-wife long yeah which I can
appreciate it I guess
I really really like Petraeus's Ark
there was that part when he finds out
he's a God he's kind of a dick
especially to Sindri at one point which
Kratos calls him out for after
everybody's like tired of caring about
little people and their little problems
and like in his defense I just he was a
sick kid he didn't get to get out and
explore a lot like but like I like how
toward the end he's this just confident
dude Kratos like stop him like bothers
running out the the giant attack Freya
and TRAI stops him and then he's like an
actual throughout the game I think the
gameplay in the story actually let you
rely on at Reyes more and more
especially because like his like you
were saying P like his magic arrows kind
of get yeah especially as lightning ones
which is what I like dumped all
experience into as soon as I could but I
really like a tres is arc and then like
kratos says when they're looking at the
murals in Jotunheim is kind of his story
toward the end of it if not the whole
time you didn't know it feel like that's
the logical conclusion I'd like Kratos
was gonna die and yet to play as betray
I thought he might get to work
afterwards Sony Santa Monica took a lot
of risks with this game I was hmmm I
found myself thinking throughout the
game Kratos probably gonna factor in the
end that suits the whole theme of him
preparing at Reyes for the world without
him at his mom yeah I guess like
seriously like beating the Valkyries
brings you to a bigger fight and the
whole point is to open up Valhalla so
that people can actually go somewhere
they die right now all hallows clothes
and that's why there's all these like
I'm dead running around the world all
right so there's opera there's seriously
opportunities for other things to happen
I feel like I don't think Chris the
question mark is in the year I mean what
happened maybe at the third game you're
playing as a trace or like that's my
prediction then you have to like you
don't have the whole co-op angle but in
general I'm like I said I love how this
like balance is that it's a kind of a
reboot mechanically but it's also
acknowledge the past in a cool way kind
of like again I keep saying arise new
Uncharted 4 and the way they address
Kratos character and the way they
Naughty Dog addressed Nathan Drake but
it also sets up like its whole new saga
and one thing that we wanted to talk
about before that like a lot of people
might miss there's that one you know
those cabinets you're opening up in at
radius is reading the runes or whatever
they are the legends
there's one
that you see and in saying like oh he
was was it tear the giant traveling to
all the no tears 'god he forgot a war
which is how they just find the name of
the game mysterious yeah north got a
board on ideas okay I was visiting these
other realms just your cute like
knowledge because he was actually a very
peaceful even God of War and they kind
of set up like oh he visited you know
crease what are those drugs in the
Cork's no rhythms symbols from different
lands they mean war I how do you this
one I know too well you see credo
society also is the class and then even
again there's another time where they
mentioned like Egyptian gods and they
are setting up this world where all
these different pathologies like exist
at once yeah and so the idea of like man
what if this new you know series of
games it doesn't even just contain
itself to Norse mythology what if they
start to sneak in like other things you
see the Eye of Horus up in the top left
of it yeah ruin it and they got
established that like Odin is like this
figure who wants to like have an
everything that he can't touch and I
would include other realm us around this
place I think there's still a lot of
stuff to mind out of Norse mythology I
definitely I don't necessarily need them
my behavior but either way it seems like
there's a lot of ways they could go from
here I'm gonna side to see what they do
I'm also a bit like see who might
directed like Corey para la grab such a
great job in this and he did got aboard
too but they are no they're not averse
to switching it up I mean there's still
two realms locked in this game yeah mr.
de laatste
Asgard and Finland
[Music]
[Music]
I never expected myself to be like
actually like excited about like God war
in the sense of like I just want to talk
about the story and like the characters
in the world it was what's next which is
so crazy
yeah I mean just just the fact of what
this game does for the God boy series in
general just the kind of like the way
that it it takes this character Kratos
and totally like expands upon and
actually acknowledges all this terrible
stuff he's done because we always hated
him he was always a jerk but then we
have this story in this new one that
makes us care about him that makes us
like understand it empathize with his
play and how that stuff has impacted him
like seriously like all the different
things it does with its story by the end
of it especially with Kratos is are
interesting one thing I love about this
game so much it's it's just unexpected
it's huge surprise like I did not expect
that God working to make me get so
invested into its story at least in this
way
[Music]